I I took marijuana and I've been talking
about this on stage trying to figure it
out said I want to sound hacky because I
know there's guys that have done it but
I've had times where your brain starts
having independent conversations with
itself and he's like oh you're so high
he's a gay man do I have a question do I
remind you to breathe and you're like oh
[ __ ] yeah and then and then I don't have
mine and then you're like wait I'm not
breathing and he's like well we haven't
been breathing in a while like and then
you start going
that's the worst when you start going
you know your heart's racing and I've
had that a number of times and and
that's why I don't really eat marijuana
I'll smoke it but I smoked it in really
small I would do vapor it's very real
small yeah yeah edibles I don't that was
a trouble man like Joey were those Death
Star's dude dude what's wrong with you
man
Joey slipped my dad marijuana have you
heard this story yes you tried yeah Oh
Joey comes to Easter one year and he's
got [ __ ] edible popcorn and he goes
oh mr. K you want to see the devil's dip
tonight and my dad's like what's that
Joe he's so aggressive yeah yeah Easter
no no I know and my dad just takes a
handful of popcorn did he know what it
was I had no idea there's a picture I
don't know where you can find it if you
look online it's on my facebook my
personal one there's a picture of Joey
giving the popcorn of my dad it's four
pictures
my dad eating it they're all connected
like like like you're in a month
my sister's going what the [ __ ] and then
me laughing hysterically and then I was
forced to eat marijuana with my dad so
my dad's like buddy what do I do and I
was like I'll go in with you and so I
ate it and I don't like eating marijuana
but we had the greatest [ __ ] night of
our lives it didn't get weird we're
sitting out it's like probably 7 o'clock
it's we're still very high having a
cigar having a whiskey and I say to my
dad like I said my dad why don't you
like me because I'm high I'm comfortable
and he goes I don't know I was wondering
about that hold on this is greatness
hold on hold on hold on I got it it's a
good question I've been thinking a lot
about that late man I can't figure out
it's your [ __ ] face your whole life
is that [ __ ] ice mark don't like that
face here the shape your face was was
your dad a seasoned triple O's does he
smoke weed alone oh no no
yeah not long okay this is great okay so
keep going I'm sorry so I he goes I've
been thinking about that a lot my dad
didn't go to therapy
now he's high and he's like he's humbled
and he goes you remind me of my dad and
I said okay and he lost his dad when he
was 13 and it really [ __ ] him up it
really [ __ ] him up forever like tough
anybody you like he'll be walking
through Gelson's and see like a
something that his dad used to like to
put on his sandwiches and just start
crying and and he goes you remind me my
dad and I come afraid to get close to
you because I look at your lifestyle I
think you're just gonna die and I said
okay I go I'm not gonna die he hold on
you at this time I am probably right
around for you 42 okay not young and so
I go how can we fix this
he goes I don't know I said well like
what an honest guy though what an honest
guy not thankfully we never said it's 42
years go by
yeah hisskill highest [ __ ] yeah won't
you like me think about that yeah he's
like obviously I love you I just you
make me uncomfortable had a weird
relationship there father
yes unaware of it unaware of it until my
parents got divorced
22 to 21 kind of older yeah and unaware
of it that we didn't have like like just
he just didn't know how to like
sometimes you call him and say I love
you and I'll go okay you know that's his
generation
yeah that's his generation and so that I
say to my dad I go I go think how can we
fix this and he goes I just I want I
need I need you to do a lot of things
you're not willing to do I said like
what he goes I need you to get a
cardiologist I need to get any searched
list off all these things they want to
see that you're not gonna die he wants
to prove that I'm not gonna die I go
listen I don't care I go if you want to
you be in charge that and he goes he
literally lit up he's like I can get you
a cardiologist I go you do all of it get
get your cardiology or medical guys you
get them online you pick him for me and
I'll go and we'll and that and he's like
he's like you do that for me I was like
yeah I love you like I don't want I want
you to like me like I want you to be
able to have dinner with my family and
not be over judged judging me everything
I do cuz if I would go to eat something
more he'd lose his mind if I had another
drink he'd lose his mind and he would be
very passive-aggressive his dad passed
away from what
stroke and it's and his dad he's like my
dad was the life of the party you seem
to be the life of the party those are
the guys that die fast I just
and my dad's never like that's deep
emotion for him man yeah that I mean I I
got chance that's fascinating to me his
dad died at like 40 yeah have you had a
cardiology that was the vision right he
had biggest problem is I went to the
cardiologist he goes you're perfect
I did a CT scan he goes zero blockage
and I started eating like a [ __ ] pig
and that's how I got to be 265 pounds is
that I'd literally because they gave you
the gave me the green light put me on
all the medicine and I was like so I
can't died from this because I was I was
judging it I was eating healthier
because of I didn't know if I was
healthy or not when you see my back
ripple and I pull myself up like a champ
like a champ through 30 times fast while
talking to you
why wouldn't I give that to you as it's
a gif it's a gift it's a gift